this movie stars Channing Tatum who has
got to hold the biggest record 14th
clenches in a movie the eagle stars
Channing Tatum and Jamie Bell and Donald
Sutherland and is directed by Kevin
Macdonald the director of state of play
came out in 2009 one of my favorite
movies of that year and very underrated
so that was really the only reason I was
looking forward to this movie because
Kevin McDonald did a great job
that film was directed very very well so
I was excited Channing Tatum plays a
commander in a Roman army and after a
series of mishaps he's injured in his
force to be honorably discharged from
the Army now he has a lot of honor and
dignity and everything is one of those
guys who's like lives by the sword dies
by the store there's like you know
nothing else in his life he has he lives
for nothing but to be a soldier and
defend Rome and have honor and dignity
for the rest of his life his father who
is now dead lost a very important Roman
relic called the eagle a long time ago
in a Roman forest far far away he sets
out on the journey into enemy territory
with Jamie Bell his slave to find this
Roman relic and restore his family's
good name
I started out really not liking Channing
Tatum he just gave bad performance after
bad performance step up GI Joe he was
just bad you know and then I saw Dear
John and you know he actually had some
really good scenes in Dear John where he
did a really nice job and I was really
impressed on top of that one of my
friends has actually met him and said
he's a really really nice guy
so I've grown to kind of like him a
little bit hey he's not that bad this
movie he has some things we're just like
okay yeah you're pushing a little bit
but he's really not that bad he has kind
of stopped clenching his teeth dude no
one just stands there and grits their
teeth know what that's because that's
how you make it up those little muscles
move you grit your teeth no one just
stands there both the films started out
really well I was getting into it it was
like this is gonna be cool he's
commanding this army and everything it
was suspenseful it was well
rekted it was it was it was getting need
it was getting gritty and then he got
injured and it just kind of got like
really slow all of a sudden lots of
walking and trekking and talking to
people and the uninteresting story it
just felt like something was missing
from the film of some kind of
testosterone fast-paced Drive or
something but no it's just very slow and
even though the film started out really
well it just got really solemn all of a
sudden and even though it picked up in
the end in the last 20 minutes or so
we're actually got kind of exciting when
the film and then I'm just kind of like
yeah man what so I thought I've been
analogy the eagle is like McDonald's
food sometimes are you go to McDonald's
just really in the mood for McDonald's
you're thinking I want this this is
gonna be good I'm excited about this and
when you start eating the McDonald's
you're like this is gonna be good
then halfway through you're just kinda
like you know just gets kind of like
yeah sometimes your sandwich is made
really well there's parts of it that
seem like wow this is actually really
well made and then other times they just
completely forget the bun on your
chicken sandwich or something
what the age and by the time you're done
eating you're just kind of like that's
what it was like with the Eagle is
starting out great halfway through I'm
like what the heck it seemed like a
whole bunch of stuff was missing and by
the time it was over I was like yeah so
now what do I do
but there are a good qualities for this
film there are good scenes between the
actors there are a few good action
scenes and towards the end I actually
got kind of intense and I was getting
into it Ken McDonald did a great job
with his directing for state of play but
his style just does not work for this
film is there a director left in
Hollywood who knows how to film action
scenes zooming in on the fight and
shaking the camera does not mean it's
exciting it's so cheap as such an easy
way out to film an action scene and I'm
really getting sick of it the film is
always watchful however at times it gets
really boring and so I'm gonna give it
two and a half out of four stars